but I think that it's good for you guys
to be educated because usually I would
only do this for the bag Chasers
um so link is in the patreon as well as
pinned to the top of the chat for y'all
to be able to join the patreon
um but but specifically you know it's
always a lot of speculation about a lot
of things I see it happening across the
internet and things like that so instead
of this being one of those situations
where it continues to get messy
specifically I want to just get down to
the to the nitty-gritty of what what
contracts look like on YouTube I am a
person that specifically does
um I hire people right I do that type of
thing I bring people in and all that
other type of stuff and pearl does also
and so uh Pearl and I are going to have
a conversation
I'm gonna go ahead and bring her up and
then we're gonna get started we're gonna
get it popping so let me go ahead and
bring Pearl up real quick
what's up p
hello
are you back on vacation
I'm off vacation now I'm back in
business
you ain't spend a lot of time enough
time vacationing
seem like the minute that you went on
vacation
it turned into not so much of a vacation
well there might be another vacation
coming you know
but yeah I I
want to get into like the business
aspect of uh YouTube but specifically I
think the hottest topic uh probably over
the last three or four days four or five
days is contracts right and so you know
I wanted you to come up here and kind of
give you a perspective because it's easy
for a lot of people to speculate
um and then I'm gonna give my
perspective based off of like
objectively telling you of whether or
not I think you should modify some
things or you know how I would do it a
little bit differently maybe I don't
know but I think it's a lot of
speculation but it's easier to just hear
it directly from you
um and get your perspective on it versus
just doing all of the speculation so
um
obviously we know that there's a lot of
contract conversations going on and
things like that
um what do you think about the whole
situation in general before we get into
like different specifics or what we
think about contracts in general
um well I will say there's a lot of
information about the the contracts that
are apparently here so
um I'd like to say that the numbers that
they're using are false
and I don't really know where they got
those from but
um the the one
the one I'm trying to like be as broad
as possible but like the one that I
wanted to go in to like what exactly
we add to a contract if that makes sense
so like a lot of people don't understand
like the value added when you sign to a
company versus doing it on your own and
like what the difference is so I thought
we could talk about that well let's
start there right because uh before we'd
even get into like a specifics aspect or
certain certain certain details of a
contract
um and obviously this is not
pertaining to anybody that's on any of
our staffs contracts or anything like
that
um we would never have those type of
conversations because you know that's
between us and whoever it is that we
doing business with however a lot of
people think or they they get these
numbers right they get these 70 30
numbers or whatever like that and I
personally think it's it can be a good
thing
uh or it can be a thing that may not be
so beneficial depending on the details
or whoever it is that you're doing
business with so for example you have a
very very very large platform very few
people
um are able to build up to over a
million subscribers
um and so you having that ability to be
able to leverage a platform
to blow somebody else up is a huge added
value that I think that a lot of people
don't really take into consideration
what do you think about that
um I would say the biggest thing about
like signing with me is you just don't
have to do anything like other than show
up and talk
so it's um I I do think like two you
also get all the collabs like that I get
I always try to get like my talents when
I have a collab that they can collab
with them too
so they automatically get all of the the
collabs they get the editing they get
the cameras they get the studios they
get all of the shorts they get the clips
they get everything so you're telling me
that the only thing that your people
have to do is just show up and talk
show up and talk that's it because I
always was trying to think of like what
I would have wanted to do like because I
always think of when I was
when I was like 21 or 22 and you could
go the route of like learning all this
stuff about YouTube right and you could
learn how to do that and you know
there's no shame in that you know like
honestly in the long term it's a really
good option but when it comes to
um I don't know I was just thinking when
I was 21 if I could just show up and
talk it would have been so much easier
than learning all this equipment if when
you were 21
you did you had a YouTube platform right
how many subscribers do you think you
had
maybe no I think I got it I started my
channel in 2020 um I had like 20 000
subscribers for like a year
um I was on Tick Tock for like a year
before that and I almost had a million
on tick tock
um tic tac's a lot quicker though it's
like a different platform and so you
decided to transition what made you
transition over in
um more into YouTube was it anything but
in particular or was it just that yo I'm
tired of tick tock or I'm having
problems on Tick Tock why did you
transition more into YouTube like why
did you start to spend more time trying
to build your YouTube platform
uh they banned my tick tock
and
um my first video was like a house tour
so
um basically
when I did the house tour
um I just saw that the ad rates were a
lot better on tick tock
yeah it was more money it was way more
money over here
um but I've been on
um YouTube for a long time too and it's
funny because me and angry man we was
talking
um because he was here in Detroit and so
we were talking in the studio and he was
like yo it was
it was so much harder because we had to
figure it out on the Fly we had to build
the plane while we were trying to fly it
at the same time but a lot of people
look at
um the successes or they look at what
they think we make and things like that
off of YouTube and things like that and
they think that they know what it takes
in order to build a platform but the
thing that I'm always asking myself is
okay well if you know it
then how come you you haven't done it
like how come
what that is what do you think about
people that criticize other people
that's actually putting the work in
matter of fact let me back up let me
back up for a minute
what is your days like
like when you when me and you connected
in Miami because we had actually been
talking about connecting for a long time
but it just didn't align with our
schedules until we both was in Miami at
the same time
what was your what was your schedule
like because I know but if I say it it's
gonna seem like I'm biased what is your
schedules like
schedule was like call it I
oh my gosh that was horrible because
they lost my bags too but I think I did
three podcasts a day roughly in Miami
two to three I would go I think I did
the sauce cast panel I did a show with
the jededia Villa chick and then I I did
a panel with you guys so I did three
panels okay and I put together the panel
at night myself yeah I was there
but then at the very next day I think
the next day then you came over to mine
you came over to my Airbnb and then you
was leaving going to go and do another
one and you was telling me that I needed
to go and do another one too
and you was trying to push me at the
same time
well I just
just content with you
to come
but I mean your work schedule is crazy
like even sometimes me and you may
FaceTime or whatever like that and we
own completely different time zones like
right now it's 9 30 at night where it's
4 30 p.m Eastern over here
um and you in the studio every single
time that I'm talking to you you're in
the studio every single time I'm talking
to you in the studio you you spin the
overwhelming majority of your time
living eating and breathing Studio
I live in my studio actually yeah I'll
sleep in my studio sometimes I literally
don't know my studio
yeah yeah
um yeah that's
done transition from like doing my own
channel to like managing others and
there's just been a lot of like
challenges that I have you know I tell
you about them didn't really see coming
um
but yeah a lot of people don't know how
much it takes to like go into it like
first you have to coordinate everybody
you have to budget you have to like
gosh there's just so much that goes into
it and like people think that
it's just simple you know what do you um
a lot of times me personally and then
after this I want to go into the actual
contracts me personally I have a lot of
problems because I deal with people
um being late a lot of people don't work
as hard as I work and that bothers me
sometimes
um guests sometimes earn on time and
panel members aren't on time Talent is
not on this necessarily not on time all
the time sometimes they don't even show
and then you know you'd be trying to
call and figure out what's going on and
things like that when you think about
what it takes in order to run a
successful business let alone content
creation platform
what do you think is the difference
between people that look at it as maybe
from the talent perspective like a
worker or an employee and people that
kind of look at it from listen this is
my baby I'm an entrepreneur what do you
think the mindset is between the two
um I think the difference is people
it's just like a mindset I don't know
it's just you have to be really
passionate about it like you will not
get anywhere if you're not passionate
about it
so yeah for me I just love making
content I love this
so when you when you think about let's
get into the contracts right
um
and in a general sense
what what is your mindset behind like a
70 30 split what is your mindset behind
it
well so for me it's like there's just a
lot of costs that come with it right so
um one the editors you you get a
full-time editor two you get a full-time
thumbnail person so you can literally
put out as and you get a full-time
Clipper so whenever you live stream we
always have clippers that are just like
they're you put them as an editor on
your channel so they'll just pull the
clips for you title them for you put
thumbnails on it and then you also have
a full-time editor so if you want to do
like some pre-recorded stuff like we
just did a dating show
and so that takes like you know two days
to like really because it's like an
in-depth ton of content type of thing
um you also get recruiters so you get I
think we have like 20 recruiters that we
pay
um and they get any type of guests that
you want so you can just tell them hey I
want to do a show with strippers and
then boom you can get some strippers
I don't realize how hard it well let's
let's go by that point by point right so
for me I do a combination of the
recruiting myself because I know that if
I'm the person that's actually sending a
message or I'm the person that's because
like my recruiting process may be
different from your recruiting process
and you know you feel free to share or
not share certain Secrets if you want
one too but my recruiting process is I
have people on my staff that actually
recruit and I make sure that my studio
was actually in the downtown area where
I can go and interact with people on a
regular basis and then I build
relationships and then I wind up
recruiting certain people
um and then I might even be sending some
DMS myself because I know that Nissan in
the DM actually makes it a little bit
more credible or I'll give my my account
to somebody else for them to send
certain DMS while I'm doing taking care
of somebody else how hard do you think
it is of recruiting
recruiting we finally just figured it
out oh my gosh that was the hardest part
though I will say recruiting Because one
it's expensive like it's hard to do uh
yeah
um so the way we set it up is we have a
website and the recruiters can see on
the websites like a backup like it's not
public it's just us and see if there's
like lots available for the week
and so then they they basically go in
and they book the person so they'll like
put three or four guests whatever they
want to do they'll sign up and all the
topics are like listed there does that
make sense but do you uh how do you deal
with like even when people sign up but
they don't necessarily show up because
you may not have enough people or you
may have too many people how do you deal
with that
uh you book you book double so I always
want
loud
my um that's our new assistant her
name's Helen shut up
I think
I think a perfectionist so if there's
anything that he doesn't like you'll
know
uh was I talking about no you were
saying
my always my rule of thumb is thumb is
and girls say they're gonna come show up
men are
left like right like I'd say men 70 of
the time will show 60. I never get guys
that cancel uh I get girls that flake
out
or they'll just be super duper late a
lot of different times
so but you see your your process is a
little bit different than mine because
I'm at the point where I think I just
want to have regular people
um reoccurring a little bit more until I
do this new show that I'm working on but
I'm having regular people reoccurring
that I'm that I'm working on a little
bit more
um but you have new people rotating in
and out on a regular basis and so it's a
lot more difficult for you and I see why
you have to book double
yeah
um it depends like we we have an
incentive for new guests just because
um
it helps us build like the database of
guests
um we used to have more of like a
recurring but recently we had to rebuild
like the whole database because we were
using a company and the company wasn't
really filling the slot so it just so
you had to you literally had to pay a
company to recruit for you
yeah I tried it uh for like a couple
like two months but they just weren't
filling the slots we kept having to
cancel shows
so yeah I paid them and like then I
would kept having to like fill all the
slots myself because I will recruit like
the first um I think in June or July I
stopped recruiting like full time and if
it's like a big panel I'll like hand
pick who I want on it you know if it's
like we have a good guest in town or
whatever but when it comes to like
recruiting
um
yeah they just they just kept not
filling the slot so I had to let them go
but then we were kind of at square one
because one I lost my Instagram
so I already yeah you did you did before
we're gone I was like no no why God why
and then they stopped um they stopped
recruiting for us and so they weren't
gonna just like give us their list you
know we stopped using them and then yeah
so we had to blessing is a godsend oh my
gosh he is I I speak so highly of this
man because blessing okay blessing is
like incredibly loyal what does blessing
do what is blessings position what is
blessing we hear about blessing all the
time but blessing don't like being on
camera give us a little bit of insight
just a little bit of insight On Blessing
um blessing was our like producer
full-time um and he we just promoted him
so now he manages so he's training
another producer and he's a little bit
more into management
so yeah he just he just so you run in a
full in-house staff
so my goal is I want
um my talents to be able to like keep
this studio here
and then I can go to Chicago and I can
just leave it because I'm like I don't
know I told you not Chicago
well my dad has the compound I don't
know we'll see I know well I know that
but that's what I got flights and you
can stay in Chicago is much closer than
Nashville took Chicago or London Chicago
right it don't take as long to get over
there whereas you set up in Nashville
you can set up in in Florida somewhere
it's much easier to recruit talent in
those locations specifically it's much
better from a tax perspective from you
know looking at it in the business sense
but so you you like being close to
family you homesick it kind of I mean
it'll depend so I have
it depends how big if
we there's two routes I could go here
right we could have locations in
different cities and that's something
we're like kind of playing around with
but I would need
um someone to like man like I just don't
see myself like if we go that route it
has to be someone else managing it it's
not going to be me because I just it's
gonna stress me out too much and I my
goal is to get out of management and be
able to just be more of like a talent
um
you know it's never happened all right
never
you I think I'm I'm having trouble
transitioning like right now I'm
starting to move away from and starting
to do more of the
I can't stay away it's some it's almost
like the minute that I that I replace
myself I find something else for me to
do just because I love what I do like I
love creating content I love new stuff I
love working and it's hard although I do
hope you do because like I know you even
did a live stream we ain't even got to
talk about personal conversations you
did a live stream talking about all of
the health issues
that come along with overworking right
and it is like I'm an insomniac at this
point I'm Only Sleeping three four hours
a day on a regular basis I know that you
don't hardly sleep because you're always
working and even when you're on vacation
and you're not necessarily on vacation
so it's just hard it's hard to turn it
off once you so used to working and
running and living in a studio and stuff
like that it's very very hard but a lot
of times like the stuff I do is work is
more of the management stuff but like I
love making content I love putting
together videos so it's it's funny
because people be like oh you work a lot
but to me it's like fun you know I just
enjoy doing this
all right so let's get into the the
nitty-gritty right because I'm sure
we'll come back to it because I could
talk about this type of stuff all day
right just I mean this is the type of
stuff that we talk about when we're on
the phone or whatever but let's go into
contracts so
you I want to go into some of the stuff
you already said you said you get an
editor which a lot of people or editors
a lot of people clearly don't understand
um how much time it takes for a lot of
people to edit a video especially whole
shows especially interviews especially
panels or anything like that
um I think that the editing process is
probably the thing that kills most
channels because most people can't
they would rather just be they would
rather just get on a camera and talk and
be the content or or be the talent
versus having an editor you said they
have an editor which that's very
expensive for me
um because I have two editors and then
you said they get a thumbnail person now
a lot of people is probably will take
the thumbnail person and they will say
well that's not that big of a deal tell
tell tell me how big of an impact it is
to have a person that specifically
creates thumbnails for the video
well because my I call them Clippers I'm
out of that word I don't think it's like
official
um
clips from either long videos or streams
so these are like five to 12 minute
clips and they'll put a thumbnail in
like a title and they do everything we
do 10 a day
yeah
yeah 10 a day I think we might have
rolled back on a couple channels to
maybe five to seven a day but so if you
if you're in like if you're here and you
put out enough content like they'll do
10 a day for you and we also appease
like we really like to give a lot of
creative freedom to the people that work
here so if you have like a video idea
like I'll pay to put it together and
we'll try it um if you
have
um if you are you know filming it like
if someone's filming so much that one
editor isn't enough I'll get you a
second it's not a big deal like I'm here
to give as many resources to the people
working here so they can just sit down
and do nothing and just film
all right so kind of give me some of the
details of like a contract let's say I'm
Anton right and
you don't or you know me but you don't
know me like you don't know me as the
business Anton you just know Anton right
so Anton comes and Anton has a Channel
of a hundred let's just say
40 000 subscribers 50 000 subscribers
right and then you would offer me a
contract what would the details of that
contract look like
and I'm not I'm like I don't want to
edit listen I just want to come in I
want to cook up I want to do what it is
that I want to do as far as like talk
about what I want to talk about I want
to blow my channel up
um I don't make a whole lot of money on
YouTube I know that most people
um on YouTube on average makes less than
a thousand dollars a month
that is a fact most people on YouTube
make less than a third thousand dollars
a month the overwhelming majority of
people so even though people may have a
decent amount of subscribers
they don't make enough money to where
they can quit their job or anything like
that so you know I'm coming in and I'm
trying to blow my channel up what would
that look like for me or what would a
standard contract look like for me
um well it depends so you're making 1K a
month on YouTube
well let's assume that I am
1K a month
um see I'm I'm a bit new I'm a bit new
to it so uh the way what I would look at
is I'm always trying to give them the
resources to cover what they're already
making so they're like lifestyle doesn't
go down
um the way that I do that is I look at
other channels that are similar and I'll
project like how much I think they could
make
um and look at percentage
now it just depends because it also
depends like you you just want to do
nothing right I just want to come in and
talk
like I just want to talk I want to drop
videos on a regular basis I want shorts
to give me some more visibility to blow
my channel up and and see it's really
not even fair using me because I know
too much
like I know the impact of what you mark
you know how you Market certain things
in order to get more visibility so that
you can get more people to move over
into other account you know the other
long-form content I know too much right
but I'm trying to dumb it down just for
people that have no clue or no
understanding of what this what it does
for you when you have a machine behind
you when you have editors and Clippers
and and all of these different people
and producers and the cameras
um what what what was some somebody that
let's let's remove the Forty thousand
let's say I'm a person that come to you
you notice that I'm a halfway decent
talent I have no Channel or what nothing
like that what does that look like for
me
no Channel you got to build me from
scratch
I'm a Build-A-Bear
how much
okay
like five to ten pay a month on you
so you spending five to ten thousand
dollars a month on me
and I usually do three years with like a
six month to one year out clause but why
would you why would you do one six
months to one year Outlaws
um I think that that's a bad deal for
you
well I just if in case
I don't think you should do that
okay what would you do what would you
say
I was structured completely different
right I would say
okay this is how I would do it first I
would do it differently because
um
I wouldn't have them have their own
channel
under me
right I would let them have whatever it
is that they wanted to do for themselves
the difference though is that you don't
get to use my resources for your Channel
right the visibility that comes along
with working with me being promoted on
my channel whatever and so on and so
forth so the percentages I would do my
percentages completely different right
the way that I would do my percentage is
you're I already understand that you
utilizing my platform to get more
visibility because you don't even have a
platform you don't have that much
visibility you're not you don't have no
motion so anytime you associate with me
or you use utilizing my platform you
getting the benefit of it not
necessarily me right so I will let you
have your own platform like I wouldn't
take a cut from your platform at all you
can have it completely now we can do it
two different ways either we can create
a completely new platform and we can
partner with it so you're going to be
the face of it you're going to be the
talent of it you're gonna be the person
that's talking on a regular basis and
then you can use my resources in order
to do it and then we can just split it
50 50. but we gonna be 50 50 in that
platform forever you don't get to have
it I don't get the Habit if we want to
renegotiate I can buy you out later or
something like that then that's cool but
if I would I would start everything that
we do
I would have it to where we are going to
be partners in this thing Forever Until
but if you want to use my resources for
your platform then that's a completely
different conversation that's how I
would do it so it's interesting because
I have it like after three years it's
yours you can keep it right which I
think that that's I think that that's a
bad deal for you honestly
I've already done built it up
want someone that doesn't want to be
there you don't even like I just I'm
never gonna try to like keep someone in
something they don't want to be in well
the way that this the reason why it
works better this way is because you
remove anything that they can say
negative about you because now they have
a vested interest in their own success
see if your channel fails or you're not
making the type of money that you want
to make
then that's on you because now we take
an equal risk right your channel is your
channel so now you can't you can't blame
me for anything that you doing wrong
right but if we in this thing partnered
and then we say well this channel is
only making this amount of money or so
on and so forth because it's completely
separate from my platform and your
platform
but
it make whatever it make
and then we remove see I think your one
you're one issue Pearl if I had to
criticize how it is that you do
something your one issue is that
um you don't take into consideration the
costs that you're incurring
while while putting together other
people's platforms so the way that I
would do it and I would say listen this
is the cost of what it takes in order to
run your channel right we can split it
or you can take less risk or you can
take more risk we can do 70 30 we can do
50 50 or we can do 75 25 in your favor
but the difference is that you're gonna
have to take all of the risks along with
me
right that's the difference because then
it removes any excuses it removes any
complaints if it fails it's because you
didn't work it you didn't do what you
were supposed to do because we still
gonna move over here and we still got
the machine to help promote you but the
difference is that I take expenses out
total right so let's just say for
example we bring some uh a talent over
here specifically for your platform and
it costs us x amount of dollars in order
to do so that x amount of dollars is
supposed to come out of
the total the the total revenue that
that channel is generating and then we
split down after that whatever it is
that we make from that so if we gonna do
a 50 50 partnership then that means that
we're going to remove the costs and all
of the uh what marketing promotion
whatever it costs in order to take it
out of that
and then we gonna bust down that bag
separately but I think that you and
current all of the costs which means
that you are responsible for the
entirety of the contract which then
makes them be able to give you a hundred
percent of the blame
as a disgruntled employee or a person
that didn't like their particular
contract
I think when you make them have a vested
interest in whatever it is that happens
in this thing it also gives them a
responsibility and it removes any kind
of accountability on your end because
you can't say that I didn't do my part
um you have the after the expenses that
you split it 100 percent
a better way to do it honestly
my gosh that's so
much I would do it differently because
they first of all they already benefit
and off of you they benefiting just from
the fact that they get Association and
they get visibility to go along with it
like that's visibility that most people
would pay for people pay to have their
artists and other artists videos or To
Do song with them
right the people that have the level of
visibility that you have I will be
charging people
I would be charging them what do you
mean we blowing you up
get give me give me an artist or not an
artist artist give me one of your
talents or somebody you don't have to
say their name specifically but give me
somebody within a uh
uh four month three month six month one
year window how many subscribers can you
can you grind them up to give me a real
life scenario that
started in
and I think I could do it faster now
because I the scheduling I was really
bad at for a while but um she got 40 000
Subs in like three months 40 you do you
know how hard it is for most people to
get 40 000 Subs in three months
you know how hard that is well you know
how hard it is
Michael I think started out like
30 000 and he's or man he might have
been a little higher 40 50 and he he's
at 70 now so
listen people people I lose money on
certain people just because I'm too nice
Mike I give I I give people you know a
lot of times and another thing that I
think you're doing wrong is that you
already signing them before
um
without making them prove theyself
like for me you got to be around I got
to see how you are I got to see how you
move how you work with the team or
whatever it's almost like you're an
intern without even knowing you an
intern a lot of people don't even know
that I'm watching them or I'm paying
attention you know what I'm saying they
just around sometimes they might jump on
the panel and so on and so forth like I
let people show who they are without any
obligation from me whatsoever
and then I start to evaluate okay listen
I don't even say nothing to them yet I
just be like hey listen here's some
money yo I appreciate you for for
hanging out here you know what I'm
saying doing what you do adding value or
whatever and everybody that's rocking
with me that has come on my team
organically nobody has just come on my
team as a result of Hey listen I'm gonna
fill out a resume or so on and so forth
unless I'm looking for an editor or
unless I'm looking for somebody
specifically I never I recruit
completely different
I recruit completely different
so for me I believe that you should
literally have them take on
the costs
and then it removes any kind of
responsibility that come along with that
or they can do it the other way right
because I think that the way you're
doing it is fine if you say the only
problem I say with you is I think that
you that six month Clause but they get
to keep their
out the window I'm not doing it
one year out the window I'm not doing it
because then listen all you're doing is
you building up their channel for them
to be able to walk away and say well
okay thank you haha
but you spent five ten thousand dollars
a month continuing to promote it push it
edit it all the associated costs to go
along with it I wouldn't do it no way
no way
I should have did it after expenses but
I never even thought about that but
that's the other thing like people just
don't understand how much it costs to
like blow people up that quick